selon vous à quoi correspond ce chiffre
647 millions d'euros je sais une
augmentation 647
c'est la somme que doit
au Finch absolument
tapis effectivement elle s'est exprime
pour la première fois face à Audrey
Crespo-Mara et à 7 à 8 elle doit 7 647
millions d'euros donc inutile que c'est
des sommes qu'on rembourse jamais on y
apprend qu'elle a dû quitter son
appartement que tout s'est bien été
saisis la fameuse maison rue des
Saints-Pères qui valait une fortune dans
Paris elle vit grâce à l'aide de ses
proches quel site Jean-Louis Borloo
qu'il aide et qui lui donne de l'argent
chaque mois elle vit seulement avec la
moitié de 1200 euros soit 600 euros elle
fait une longue interview de fan triste
désemparée elle confie que des merdes
tapis lui disait que la justice ne
voulait que sa peau elle dit aussi que
ils ont failli se séparer plusieurs fois
tellement ce sujet est revenu sur sur la
table
moi ce que je peux vous dire je vais
vous laisser parler parce que je vous
dis la vérité Sophie tapis c'est une
amie à moi j'ai été rue des Saints-Pères
j'ai dîné avec elle c'est une fille qui
est formidable et je l'aime beaucoup
donc je peux pas parler et Bernard Tapie
je vous dis la vérité et il a beau faire
des choses pas bien ou bien
c'est quelqu'un qui est jusqu'à la fin
c'est quelqu'un moi j'ai admiré donc je
vous laisse en parler certains disent en
gros tout ça c'est du bullshit pas avec
600 euros il s'était bien démerdé il
avait planqué des trucs en nous propose
des imbéciles et d'autres disent non il
avait pas préparé cette succession c'est
pas bien c'est quoi le truc moi je pense
que les dettes alors Sophie non mais
c'est tout à fait juste et en plus
l'appartement qu'elle avait à Paris
c'était son appartement c'est-à-dire que
ça venait de son héritage de sa famille
à elle elle a dû s'en séparer
effectivement pour pour payer les dettes
qu'il avait les dettes fiscales c'est un
peu comme Johnny Hallyday quand il est
parti il a vraiment plus rien selon toi
je ne sais pas avec combien elle vit
mais en tout cas elle est criblée de
dettes fiscale effectivement il y a des
lois qui sont faits pour protéger les
femmes comme ça elle peut pas rembourser
de toute façon elle n'aura pas assez de
temps de vie pour rembourser ni de
travail je pense que ça va être ça va
être classé sans suite puisque tout ce
qu'elle a tout s'est bien passé
à Saint-Germain-des-Prés qui a été saisi
voilà il y a pas que ça arrive
fiscaliste puis on est d'accord vraiment
suffisamment le dossier moi j'ai été
impressionné par la dignité de cette
femme dimanche dernier j'ai regardé le
truc je m'attendais à Madame Tapie
machin et je l'ai trouvé extrêmement
digne je trouve qu'elle a parlé de
Bernard Tapie de manière vraiment
extrêmement honnête en disant qu'il
était très dur à vivre qu'il avait
toujours raison qu'elle aimait par
dessus tout elle avait me raconter qu'il
avait certainement mis des coups de
canif dans le contrat etc mais qu'elle
était toujours là pour lui enfin la fin
je trouve qu'elle a elle a une elle a eu
le courage de se montrer la télé le
sujet c'est quand même que elle est un
petit peu dans le sud un peu à Paris
elle prend des taxis personne vive avec
600 euros par mois comme ça et l'idée
c'est de se dire est-ce que Bernard qui
l'aimait tant il y a eu vraiment
vraiment mort sur solide mort en disant
il faut dire ma chérie tu auras 650
millions d'euros et puis tu te démerdes
faudrait demander à Stéphane tapis qui
est souvent invité chez nous en plus et
qui la mec génial avec le Stéphane qui
est le fils de mes parents et c'est son
fils alors ils arrivent Florian mais
elle l'a très bien dit aussi il avait
tellement confiance en son étoile
tellement sûr de gagner à la fin parce
que ça avait toujours été le cas qui
s'était dit l'échéance le Crédit
Lyonnais ça sera réglé et donc ma chérie
le jour où je partirai tout sera réglé
mais ça n'a pas été Florian et oui alors
déjà une réponse parce que beaucoup de
beaucoup de gens notamment sur les
réseaux se sont rués sur cette occasion
pour dire voilà c'est un dessin elle
parle d'argent pour les raisons que tu
évoques un petit peu et en fait faut
savoir moi je sais comment c'est tramé
la préparation de cette interview ça a
été des mois et des mois de négociation
et ne voulait vraiment pas du tout
parler elle l'a fait en partie pour ses
enfants et pour d'autres raisons aussi
pour lever le voile sur tout ce qu'on
tousse qu'on se demande depuis des mois
pour dire la vérité en tout cas sa
vérité et après ce qui est vrai c'est
qu'effectivement elle ne touche que la
moitié de la retraite de députés de
Bernard Tapie qui a pas été député
pendant 30 ans donc forcément c'est pour
ça que c'est 600 euros et après là aussi
des amis de son mari qui l'aident ou
bien
c'est elle a des aides qui lui
permettent de faire ce que tu de mener
une vie qu'on échec de 10000
elle est certainement très sympathique
elle a eu 50 ans de vie de milliardaires
elle peut avoir 10 ans de vie un peu
moins facile moi je veux pas beaucoup de
gens aimeraient bien avoir la vie
qu'elle a eu c'était magots
50 ans de vie de milliardaire bah oui
Robert le fortune je voudrais savoir
c'est si elle peut pas rembourser on
peut hériter des dettes comme les
refuser donc ça je sais pas pourquoi
l'héritage d'un passif tu dis non
tu divorces moi ça m'est arrivé j'étais
malade non non j'étais mariée une fois
quand j'étais très jeune et mon ex-mari
ne m'a laissé que des dettes fiscales
mais est-ce que ça peut donc à tes
enfants mais sur l'argent sur la sur
l'argent les mariages vraiment écoute
maintenant pour répondre à ta question
et peut-être qu'une question tout le
monde se pose ici est-ce que oui ou non
on nous ment est-ce que connaissant
Bernard Tapie et son goût quand même
pour les montages financiers depuis des
années il a quand même pas un petit 4 5
millions
et qu'elle envie d'une manière ou d'une
détourner avec des copains qui lui
sortent j'en sais rien et personne n'en
sait rien en vrai voilà
l'interview que après sa mort elle l'a
maudit elle l'a détestait pendant un
moment donc d'accord tout ça c'est
interviews
pour qu'elles vivent ça me choquerait
pas et je pense pas qu'elle vivait avec
600 € et un chèque de 3000 balles de
Jean-Luc Borloo je pense hein
à 3000 balles à Paris c'est compliqué
mais on avance en tous les cas je je la
crois en tout cas et je rappelle que
Sophie sa fille c'est un ça doit être
horrible pour elle
c'est sa fille avec des boucles
d'oreilles c'est tout c'est c'était une
faute de bord une boîte de nuit avec
elle il y a un mec qui la bousculé elle
est arrivé pas ça lui a mis un pain il a
dégagé j'ai Sophie et après elle m'a dit
vas-y non bah non
et son mari ils étaient tous dans la
bagarre à Saint-Tropez son mari dit bah
viens l'arrivée du champagne non tant
pis d'abord je suis animateur je ne suis
pas courageux alors